à noter cette année encore l'excellent
succès de cette manifestation la Forêt
des Livres plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de visiteurs se sont rendus
aujourd'hui à chansau préloche je vous
propose de découvrir les recettes du
succès de cette
manifestation avec près de 200 auteurs
réunis dans la forêt de loche cette 20e
édition de la Forêt des Livres a connu
un réel succès un succès populaire qui
doit autant à la littérature qu'à la
présence de people
bonoir je pense que c'est un amalgame de
tout ça certainement parce que bon c'est
vrai
que je crois être un peu populaire alors
peut-être c'est pas innocent que les
gens soient là mais aussi ils disent
aussi bien le pè et gourmand que
l'aleman que le café du pont que tout ce
que j'ai pu commettre depuis tant
d'années voilà le cadre oh en plus c'est
d'abord l'idée est géniale d'avoir fait
ça et le cadre bon ben merci
merci toute la région qui a fait tant de
de choses pour que ça puisse exister
c'est vrai que c'est un bonheur pour les
auteurs cet événement culturel au fin
fond du lechois rassemble une foule
considérable des milliers de visiteurs
sont à la chasse aux autographes aux
photos de gens connus et rendu
accessible le temps d'un bel après-midi
d'été bonne lecture Michel voilà il est
tellement chouette ce Pierre opéré c'est
vraiment je crois qu'il est enfin c'est
comme un on le connaît tellement que
c'est comme un ami quoi c'est le côté le
cadre le fait qu'on voit des tas de gens
effectivement il y a peut-être un côté P
mais moi c'est pas ce qui non c'est pas
ce qui m'attache c'est c'est de
rencontrer des gens cette 2e édition
sonne comme une confirmation d'un genre
littéraire populaire et champêtre à
l'image de son initiateurqu jours à
l'origine de cette manifestation il y a
20 ans gonzac Sabri bien sûr enchanté du
succès rencontré par cette journée il y
a 20 ans quand j'ai réuni 25 écrivains
avec 3000 visiteurs je ne pouvais pas
imaginer ce qui se passe ici nous sommes
dépassés par le miracle et par la grâce
et aujourd'hui nous avons atteint 100000
visiteurs ce qui est véritablement le
rêve d'un écrivain être édité à 100000
exemplaires c'est quoi la recette de
votre succès avec cette manifestation en
plein air comme ça c'est mon respect
profond pour les pères les écrivains
l'amitié que j'ai pour eux et qu'ils ont
pour moi et c'est aussi le bonheur de
démontrer que cela existe en France la
culture populaire et aussi que les
Français sont des auteurs il y a 7
millions de Français qui écrivent il y a
15 % de Français qui écrivent leur
journaux intimes il y a 10 % de Français
qui griffonnent pendant leur loisirs
vous êtes content aujourd'hui je suis
content mais je ne suis pas le seul à
être content ce qui me rend encore plus
content vous l' avez compris le succès
de cette manifestation c'est d'abord le
carnet d'adresse un carnet très mondain
de gonzac ser il n'y a qu'à voir le
nombre de personnalités qui se sont
déplacé ici à chanceau-préloche au fil
des années 1995 la première page de la
Forêt des Livres se tourne dans les
années qui suivent moins de 10000
visiteurs et une trentaine d'écrivains à
peine participent annuellement à cette
manifestation culturelle et bucolique
mais dans les années 2000 ce rendez-vous
annuel prend un nouveau virage écrivain
médiatique vedette de la télé et du
cinéma s succède atti
plus Richard
Bing poivrearv un habitué et jeanormon
aini que patri de Carol mais aussi
charlesour qui reviendra d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises puis Rena
Michel et ce sont là que quelques de Ven
pour dédicacer le ouvrage ou tout
simplement dambul sous les Platan RRE
de trouvera son calme les auteurs seront
pour la plupart rentré à Paris et le
public aura encore des rêves dans les
yeux avec sur la table de chevet un
livre
dédicacé